والبدايه اذا بابرز واحدث تطور في حرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا حيث اعلن مساعد القائم
باعمال زعيم الدنيا
ان القوات المسلحه الروسيه احكام التطويقه
مدينه باخمود في مقاطعه دنياسكا وقال
» في تصريحاته لوسائل الاعلام روسيه ان
المدينه تخضع حاليا للحصار مشدد وان معارك
تدور للسيطره على الطريق السريع جنوب غربي
المدينه
600 كيلو متر عن العاصمه
وتشكل بخموت واحده من اكبر مراكز صناعات
الالات الثقيله في اوكرانيا كما انها
تساهم بنحوي 30 في المئه من الملح الصخري
في البلاد
مراسلنا عامر لافي ومن دنيا
معك عامر واخر التطورات الميدانيه
المتعلقه
فهو لا يتحدث ابدا عن ان هناك حصان قد
اطبق على هذه المدينه قبل قليل
تحدثي المتحدث باسم الجبهه الشرقيه وقال
بان المعارك مستمره وضاريه في مخمود قال
بان القوات الروسيه قصفت مواقع الجيش
الاوكراني تقريبا 150 مره خلال الساعات
الاخيره لكنه قال بان القوات الروسيه
تكبدت خسائر كبيره جراء محاولتها للتقدم
في مخموت وقال بان الجيش الاوكراني تمكن
من قتل تقريبا 350 جنديا الروسيه من خلال
الساعات ال24
واصابه حوالي 300 من الجنود الروس جراء
هذه المعارك المعارك يمكننا القول وفقا
لمصادرنا هناك بانها تدور على ثلاث محاور
القوات روسيه تحاول مهاجمه بخمول من الجهه
الشرقيه والان وفقا لهذه المصادر المعارك
تدور لمحاوله السيطره على معمل اللحوم
ومصنع الشربات الكحوليه في شرق المدينه
وعلى الاطراف الشرقيه للمدينه ايضا هناك
معارك جاريه الان في الشمال الشرقي تعلمين
وسيله قوات روسيه كانت سيطرت على مدينه
سوليدار في الشمال الشرقي وهي الان تحاول
للتقدم غربا ووصيطره على القرى ايضا
القريبه من هناك وتحديدا الان المعارك
تدور في كراسنا هور ايضا في الجبهه
الجنوبيه هناك معارك داريه تحاول قوات
الروسيه التقدم جنوبا وتحديدا عند قريه
كلاشنك بخصوص حديث الاجانب الروسي عن
السيطره وعن همم اطباق الحصار على بخمول
يمكننا ان نفصل تفصيلا يعني بشكل مختصر
وهو ان هناك طريقان رئيسيان يؤديان الى
بخمود الاول والطريق الشمالي القادم من
اسلام محمود والاخر هو الطريق الجنوبي من
كوستانتي نيفيا الى ضخمود الان بعد التقدم
الذي احرزته القوات الروسيه اصبحت قريبه
مرمانيرانها اصبح قريب من هذه الطرق
الرئيسيه وبالتالي استخدام
هذه الطرق اصبح صعبه يمكن القول بانها
نوعا ما لا نريد ان نباله لكن انها مقطوعه
ناريا لكن هناك نقطه مهمه وهو انه بين
هذان الطريقان هناك مساحات شاسعه وهناك
عدد كبير من القرى هناك طرق التفافيه
كبيره هناك مدن مدينه كاصوفيار على سبيل
المثاليه تقع بالوسط بين هذين الطريقين
والان الكثير من العتاد يصل عن طريق هذه
الطرق والكثير من المتطوعين يوصلون الطعام
والشراب الى بخمود ايضا عن طريق هذه الطرق
الفرعيه بين الكره مباشره الى مخمود طبعا
بخصوص هذه المدينه واهميته هم هي ربما
احدى المدن الصغيره في اوكرانيا لكن تكون
الاهميه هنا اذا ما تمكنت القوات الروسيه
من السيطره عليها وانها خط دفاعي جيد وقوي
جدا اذا انهار فهذا يعني ان الطريق ستكون
مفتوحه امام القوات الروسيه الى مدن كبيره
ومهمه واخص بالذكر طبعا مدينه وايضا هناك
راماتورس القريبه ايضا من ستافيا بالتالي
هذه هي كما يقول الاوكرانيين مرارا
وتكرارا تحدثه عن ان خطه الجيش الروسي
لاطباق همم قوام وسيطرتهم على مقاطعه
دونيس وهي كما يقولون هدفهم الرئيسي هو
التقدم شمالا من بخمود نحو سلافيس
وكراماتوس وايضا التقدم من الجنوب من فوق
لدار ونحو بكره في سك وبالتالي يطبقون
الحصار على عدد كبير من القوات الروسيه
الاوكرانيه المتمرزه في هذه المنطقه
الحساسه بالنسبه لهذه الحرب يعني هنا
مقاطعه بدون نت
القوات المواليه لروسيا في دنيا الناس
تؤكد انها اطبقت الحصار على باخم وتبقى
هذه الروايه ما هي اخر تطورات
نعم وسيله في واقع الامر مساله محاصره
مدينه باكونت هي مساله تتحدث عنها وسائل
الاعلام والمصادر العسكريه
المطلع والقريبه من العمليات العسكريه
يعني منذ يومين ولكن اليوم على ما يبدو تم
الاعلان والتاكيد على ذلك رسميا من قبل
السلطات المحليه هنا
اود الاشاره يعني وسيله انطلاقا من كل ما
يصدر من تصريحات سواء من الجانب الاوكراني
او من الجانب الروسي والانفصاليين في
منطقه يمكن القول ان الوضع كثيرا ما
يذكرنا بمجريات الاحداث خلال اجتياح مدينه
سليدار كانت هناك اتهامات متبادله كان
الجانب الروسيه يتحدث عن عدم عن السيطره
والجانب الاخرى كان ينفي ذلك وبعد اعلان
روسيا عن السيطره على هذه المدينه الباقيه
الجانب الاوكرانيه يتحدث لاكثر من اسبوع
انه لان هذه المدينه لا تزال تخضع لسيطرته
حاليا في مدينه باخذ
تقولي فهم الوضع لابد من الاشارات الا انه
تم الاعلان في الفتره الاخيره عن السيطره
على عده مواقع وبلدات استراتيجيه كلها تقع
في محيط مدينه باخمت الحديث يدور هنا عن
السيطره على
ابياتنا من من الجانب الجنوبي من السيطره
على
كابلي يومين في المناطق الشماليه فضلا عن
السيطره قبل ذلك على ذلك تم اقطع كل الطرق
الرئيسيه المؤديه لهذه المدينه
طريق واحد حتى هذه اللحظه لا يزال همم
خاضعا لسيطره القوات الروسيه بشكل كامل
وهو الطريقه الذي يصل مدينه محمود بمدينه
اليوم وسيله من قبل السلطات المحليه هو
الاخر حاليا همم تعملوا القوات المسلحه
الرئيسيه الرئيسيه من قوات بادنر على
توسيع السيطره على هذا الطريق
والعمليات العسكريه دائره فضلا عن ذلك
وفقا لتصريحات لو انتقلنا لتطورات الاوضاع
في داخل مدينه باخمود حاليا المعارك تجري
بالدرجه الاولى في المناطق الشرقيه
والمناطق الجنوبيه وسيله ااا
القوات بادنر في داخل المدينه وصلت الى
المواقع القطاع الخاص حيث تتمركز القوات
المسلحه
الاوكرانيه بالاضافه الى حديث عن ان معارك
تجري في المنطقه الصناعيه في
القرب من مصنع لصناعه اللحوم في المدينه
وبالفعل المعارك عنيفه وضاريه في هذه
المدينه بحسب التصريحات الصادره تدور هذه
المعارك للسيطره على كل متر هذا يعني
وعليه فانه حتى هذه اللحظه لا يكمل الحديث
عن ان هناك
في داخل المدينه ولكن ااه انطلاقا من
معطيات الاحداث في المدينه مطوقه على
الاقل وفقا للتصريحات الرسميه والجميع
المصادر العسكريه فضلا عن ذلك هناك توسع
تمدد القوات المسلحه الروسيه في اا
المناطق المحيطه في هذه المدينه هناك توجه
حاليا للسيطره على مدينتين استراتيجيتين
تقعان ايضا في المناطق الشماليه الغربيه
من مدينه باخبط وهما همم منطقه براسكافيه
وايضا
هاتان منطقتان تقعان على مرتفعات
استراتيجيه وفي حال تم السيطره عليهما في
الايام القليله الماضيه فذلك ساهل عمليات
القوات المسلحه الروسيه للسيطره على مدينه
باقمك بالفعل هذه المدينه السيطره على هذه
المدينه يحمل اهميه كبيره على الصعيد
الاستراتيجي كونها تعتبر هنا في مقاطعه
ادانيس احد اهم معاقل القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه واحد اهم خطوط الدفاع وعليه
فان السيطر عليها هذا يعني التقدم لقوات
المسلحه الروسيه نحو الشمال
الصلاه
شكرا جزيلا لكم